voir j en ai dit avec serait merci
d'être avec nous l'impossible débat et
tombe bien parce que la conclusion du
rapport est clair aucune propriété
toxicologiques
on revient pas clairement en arrière
c'est un débat qui tourne en boucle à
ben écoutez moi je pense que pas du tout
reconnaît pas les leurs le progrès là on
voit clairement que le discours de
françois des rêves et de ses zones j'ai
complètement dépassé il se base sur une
étude du cirque de 2015 qui d'ailleurs
n'a pas prouvés ni démontrés que le
glyphosate était cancérigène
puisqu'il dit que ces cancers est
probable depuis vous avez trois agences
sanitaires à l'échelle mondiale qui se
sont prononcés l'efsa se pronocer 2017
en disant en réussite en réfutant la
cancérologie t glyphosate
vous avez le père quelle agence
sanitaire américaine
terrine aux mêmes conclusions et ensuite
le canada qui viendrais homologué le 10
face à alors en ce qui concerne cette
nouvelle étude
prétendre que que les gens n'ont pas
bien fait leur boulot c'est quand même
fort de café
pour la première fois vous avez quatre
états membres4 est un membre qui ont mis
à leur dit à la disposition de l'union
européenne leurs agences sanitaires
il s'agit de la france de l'inde cesse
donc il s'agit de des pays-bas de la
suède et de la hongrie
tous ces scientifiques se sont donc
réunis pour travailler la question et
vous comprenez bien que vous ne
l'imaginez pas une seconde qu'ils n'ont
pas pris connaissance de toutes les
données dont dispose le cirque dont
disposait le cip en 2015 et donc en
ayant pris toutes les données toutes les
mises à jour qui existent aujourd'hui
que distille ils disent tout simplement
avec un rapport qui fait plus de onze
mille pages que finalement ben non ce
n'est pas un produit qui est cancérigène
ce qu on a toujours sur en fait s'il ya
la seule agence qui a prétendu le
contraire c'est le ciri encore comme je
vous le disais qu'ils disaient que
c'était quand sujets probables dont
aujourd'hui françois dérec et toutes ces
associations écologiques qui ont fait du
glyphosate un symbole sont mis dans un
coin une toque uniquement se raccrocher
qu'à une chose qui à cette étude de
glucides qui date de 2015
mais bon il faut maintenant revenir à la
raison
il est clair que cette histoire le vrai
scandale du glyphosate
c'est cette manipulation médiatique qui
a eu lieu pour faire croire à l'opinion
publique que ce produit cancérigène et
ça mon livre là l'esprit très clairement
c'est une opération de gros shows
américains
c'est une opération qui a été mis en
place par l'est les avocats américains
qui se sont saisi de cette question pour
essayer d'obtenir des milliards de
dollars à paris bayer ils ont eux-mêmes
peut-être réussir mais ça n'a rien à
voir avec la santé du tout et je tiens
aussi à souligner le fait qu' il n'y a
aucun pays dans le monde aujourd'hui aux
états-unis au canada et qui a interdit
le glyphosate donc la france ou l'europe
serait le seul à le faire sur la base
d'une étude de 2015 du cirque et idy pas
petit dit pas grand chose il faut être
sérieux aujourd'hui vous avez ces quatre
pays
ces quatre agences qui ont tranché la
question et comme le titre correctement
le monde ça donne une la voix collerait
homologation de cette molécule
et c'est une très bonne chose parce que
c'est un des produits les moins toxiques
pour la santé et les moins toxiques pour
l'environnement
je savais qu'ils le sont quand même un
peu à défaut d'être cancérigènes il ya
quand même une sorte de toxicité c'est
un pesticide
c'est un herbicide ce sont des produits
qui sont qui ont une toxicité par
définition c'est un produit qui était
mis en place pour éliminer les mauvaises
herbes pour éliminer a évidemment qu'il
est excité mais comme tout produit les
l'agriculture
j'utilise des produits qui sont toxiques
comme à l'aller victoire conventionnelle
la fête à christian des toxicités n'est
pas un problème
la question c'est une toxicité qui est
qui est maîtrisable respect qui est
acceptable
et surtout est-ce que c'est une toxicité
ou l'âme et là c'est clair pas ce n'est
pas le cas mais bien entendu on ne
déversent pas sur des champs de la de la
confiture dont tu es le mauvais l'armada
est imminent donc oui c'est un produit
toxique
je vous pose la question vous connaissez
effectivement le sujet certainement
mieux que tout le monde mais il ya quand
même une défense et parfois une manque
de un manque de confiance sont
simplement de l'opinion publique envers
ces rapports retrouvons dans les
instances européennes
ça ne vous interpelle pas justement ce
manque de confiance
la faute à qui est cette étude cette
manipulation dont on vous parlait il
n'ya que ça joue parfois voilà on nous
dit pas toujours toute la vérité sans
verser dans le complotisme à loin de moi
cette idée mais voilà on dit pas la
vérité on se rend compte après que les
choses étaient dangereuses écoutez je
pense qu'on a vu tout ce complot tisme
prendre une telle ampleur ou tout des
questions des vaccins je crois que la
population a finalement a finalement
bien compris que les agences sanitaires
qui sont en charge de notre santé font
très attention et il n'y a aucune raison
super ces mêmes agences sanitaires
n'agissent pas de la même manière pour
les questions de cet ordre là n'oubliez
pas que nous avons mis en place les
agences sanitaires pour garantir la
sécurité de nos citoyens
ce sont des agences qui sont financés
par les états se sont pas des fils des
agences qui sont financés parler parler
parler firme est le but de ces agences
est justement de voir s'il y aurait pas
eu de la part de la firme quelconque
manque une manipulation et c'est donc ce
sont des gens qui sont formés pour
regarder si justement tout a été fait
correctement
hélas pour qu'il n'y ait pas de doute
cette fois ci on a mis quatre agences de
quatre pays différents
mais que voulez vous devez le choc vous
pensez franchement c'est de varier
j'ai l'impression vous me cherchez vous
trouverez comme moi voilà je pose des
questions neutre de plus pour être
rassurés par le fait que ce ses 4
agences et qu'ils arrêtent aboutissent
exactement aux mêmes conclusions que
d'autres agences dans le reste du monde
un moment donné il faut quand même de ne
pas refaire confiance à toutes ses
agences à ce moment là on fait confiance
à qui voit si on est pas oui c'est la
même logique pour le pôle vaccins
quelque part les gens qui quittent des
gens qui pensent que les que derrière
tout ça c'est du business etc
on arrive à jamais les convaincre mais
les gens qui sont plus raisonnables ou
bien compris que tout cas humain
différent même si on comprend votre idée
mais merci gilles larivière avec stan
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france ce soir